Do you suggest any natural way to address AFIM?
Currently on medication, but would like to consider a natural supplement under professional healthcare provider.
So again, you want to look for what could be the cause, so AFIM has to do with multiple different possible causes.
The simplest cause of AFIM can be a deficiency in vitamin D and issues with vitamin D receptors, you could have genetic issues, vitamin D receptors, and those people tend to be able to take vitamin D and can't get their blood vitamin D levels up.
And imbalance in vitamin D affects the calcium channels in the endothelial layer affects the blood pressure and affects the cytotryl node and can cause AFIM.
So years ago, I remember one of my patients years ago, said her mom was an AFIM and they were going to panel her, she was completely awake and they didn't want to do that.
I discussed this with her, she brought a bottle of liquid dropper vitamin D in, gave her 30,000, I use a vitamin D, took her out of AFIM immediately.
Now I'm not saying that works with everybody, but that is the simplest solution to it if that is the issue.
So getting to the issue of AFIM, other issues with AFIM are inflammation in the brain itself.
So the midbrain is where you have control over that the issues with the SA node and inflammation in the midbrain can cause a chronic AFIM issue.
How would you know that? Well, there's a video, if you go back to cuttersclinic.com and you search in the search, they search neuroinflammation neuro N E U R O inflammation, I created a video on that it's a half hour video highly suggest you take a half hour your day and watch that.
There is a phenomena that is quite common with people that have, there's multiple different sources of neuro inflammation and brain inflammation in many times, most people don't know that they have it, they just have other symptoms and have been given labels of other diseases or syndromes and it's stepping from neuroinflammation.
So have to look at causes of neuroinflammation and how to treat it.
There's a whole phenomenon called microglial priming that go into that into detail and then a further is to be tested for neural antibodies, which would be a sidrex array seven X test.
If you have neural antibodies and or to a lesser you have microglial priming neural inflammation can cause all sorts of problems and AFIM is just one of the possibilities.